i've got my life together
we all know we all know that's a lie no
one just thinks that
okay okay i've got my life more together
okay
that's better and i was wondering i'm
like well i've had like a
drastic life change from moving to japan
and that's not because of anything to do
with japan right that's probably because
of i think
the fact that someone's holding me
accountable yeah
before if i [ __ ] up a sponsor it was
on me yeah right now there's someone
else involved
i was wondering because i'll explain
mine but did you you know when you guys
moved to japan
and you know maybe when you joined the
agency did your life change that much
did you like have a lifestyle change or
just same [ __ ] i think the biggest
change for me has been actually this
podcast yeah well we have a specific day
we come in and film
and having something on my schedule has
just completely changed my entire weekly
schedule just because i have
i have one day that's always booked off
and have to like plan around that
instead of being like i'm going to wake
up and i'm going to feel like
maybe i'll feel like working on
something today maybe i'll just feel
like playing um
ghost with sushi tsushima i don't [ __ ]
there's nothing worse i feel than
like it being a monday morning right
it's a fresh start to a new week and
you're like all right let's see what i
have to do this week and you look on
your calendar it's just
nothing this week i'm just like what do
i what do i do
how do i how do i do things now
especially especially after quarantine
you just wake up and you
you don't even know what day of the week
it is and weekends don't feel like
weekends or weekdays or just
other days i don't know most people wake
up being like oh yes it's a friday it's
the end of the week i just wake up and
it's like it is morning
but youtubers every day is the same day
yeah yeah
when everyone started working from home
and everyone was like oh yes this is
such a refreshing change to my lifestyle
which is like yeah
yeah welcome to your youtube live it's
fun when everyone's doing it and
everyone's in the same boat right then
when
you know everyone's doing their normal
life and [ __ ] it's like it's how
i mean that's how i felt though like
when we as as you said like we
started to be like all right every week
this day this time we're going to come
to the
studio and i'm just like oh
this is how normal people feel it's
quite liberating i drink coffee with
other people
i know it's great because you know when
i worked at the bbc
i worked for there for like two years um
like close close to three years and i
did not enjoy it after a while but after
moving to youtube and being freelance
and just
going by my own schedule i kind of
missed the office environment because
yeah about like a year after doing
youtube i kind of realized
man if i don't actively go out and seek
social interaction it just
doesn't happen it doesn't happen it took
me like three or four years to realize
that
do i have no friends
unless they like drag me out yeah it's
weird i kind of
yeah i kind of got that same thing
because i never had uh like a business
like
like a corporate uh experience right
like working in an office or whatever
so it's like extra exciting for me
because i'm just
because it is liberating because i've
always been even during school i've
always been one of those kids where it's
like
i couldn't study on my own like i had to
like one of those yeah like i couldn't
go home and just sit in my room by
myself what do you mean one of those
like when they'd always be like y'all
want to study together i'm like no
oh no i was always like yes i'm exactly
the same because i can't because i know
that if i go home and i'm in my own room
then i'm not going to want to study
because no one's judging me for just
being like well i couldn't just like
play some games
but when i'm around my friends i want to
talk to my friends no same here
we never when we when there was always a
group study session we'd have
in university i remember we'd always
have like the first hour was like nice
and productive we'd start going over
problems
and then it would just people would get
bored and then we just want to watch
this youtube video
yeah exactly that's always what would
happen
no i was a model asian son so i i
genuinely just like
hey do you want to go to the library and
do some study sessions
and then we put our headphones in and we
just study because if there's people
around that's a [ __ ] lie
no no no way there's no way that we and
we all met up and we
all studied yeah it's like what is why
do you think i'm so galaxy right
i'll tell you the real mvp which wasn't
my lecturer but my actual real lecturer
was
shout out to those indian youtube
lectures that were always
uploaded khan academy yeah what's that
it's like if you did maths or anything
engineering yeah there was always
like this channel i don't remember it
might have been khan academy or
something like that where they would
just
upload the lectures that are shorter and
way more informative yeah
oh like kind of like cliff notes yeah
but like
somehow they explained it better in 10
minutes than the 2-hour lecture you went
to yeah
you go to your lecture you sit there for
an hour you wouldn't take any of this in
and then when you're revising you you
search up hey um x topic like
how do i use how do i do second order
integrate uh into
integra i can't even remember just
integers um
uh and you there'd just be always this
it was always an indian guy doing the
lectures
i don't know why they're just no maths
man
they get it they get it man yeah i never
had anything like that i just i just
went
if you did any traditional route if you
did anything maths or engineering at
some point an indian man on the internet
would save you
like that's just how it is like that's
just because they i don't know why
is that maybe like only a uk thing no no
no because like it was like americans
too i think would use these
i think it's an engineering thing must
be an engineer yeah i never did
engineering
all the sciences yeah maybe yeah i never
had anything like that i mean i had like
indian lecturers like at school who were
like teaching me stuff and they were
usually like the best lecturers
yeah there's so many in engineering yeah
i didn't have like any youtube i wish i
had like a youtube channel
that i could just [ __ ] go on so i'm
being like yes solve all of my problems
for me please
thank you so i don't have to go to
classes earlier i felt so op when i went
to university and it was in english and
i was like wait the internet's useful to
the work
because like welsh internet like isn't
really a thing so anytime i'd want to
like cheat
i just couldn't because i couldn't
google any of this [ __ ] right so i
didn't know what i was looking up
yeah yeah yeah but yeah no man oh my god
my lifestyle university was so unhealthy